نعود الى ضيفنا في الاستوديو ضياء الدين
بلال الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
السوداني سيد ضياء الدين بلال هذه
التصريحات من الطرفين هل تفتح اي قوه ولو
صغيره في الجدار بالعكس هي تغلق تغلق واضح
ان كل طرف يتمسك باهدافه العسكريه حميتيه
يتمسك بالاحتقال البرهان
والمرهان كذلك يريد ان يخرج الدعم السريع
من الخرطوم ويحد من اثره دوره السياسي في
الفتره القادمه هذه ذات الاجنده قد تكون
الاشاره الاساسيه هي حديث البرهان عن
امكانيه التوقف القتال اذا خرجت قوات
الدعم السريع خارج الخرطوم واعتقد ان ذلك
المطلب لن يجد استجابه خاصه وان
القوات الدعم السريع الان هي تحتمي
بالمباني وتحتمي بالسكان فاذا خرجت خارج
الخرطوم ستتعرض الى القصف ومهما كانت
التعهدات ومهما كانت الالتزامات لا اعتقد
ان قوات الدعم السريع ستوافق على هذا
الطلب طيب كيف وج
دت مطلب
مقابل
التركيز على ضروره التخلص من البرهان
شخصيا يعني ماذا وجد في ذلك تعطي ان
الدافعه الدافعه المباشر لحميتي دافع
الشخصي وهو لا يدرك او ربما يدرك ولا يود
ان يقول بان الحرب اتجاهه هي حرب المؤسسه
حرب مؤسسه الجيش مؤسسه الجيش لها مواقف من
الدعم السريع ولها اعتراضات كانت هنالك
محاولات انقلابيه للحد من نفوز الدعم
السريع كانت هنالك اصوات داخل الجيش تم
احتقاله تطالب بالحجم النفوس
فبالتالي الموقف من حمتي ليس موقف شخصي هو
موقفه من البرهان موقف شخصي ولكن مؤسسه
الجيش موقفا من الدعم السريع كوجود كتاثير
كنيفوس طيب باعتقادك في ضوء ما قيل اليوم
في هاتين المقابلتين ما هي سيناريو
سيناريوهات المرحله المقبله هذه الصراعات
وستتحول الى الى الى حرب مدن حرب حرب مدن
اعتقد ان ذلك سياقظ وقت لا اتوقع ان تنتهي
هذه الحرب
بالضربه القاضيه ولكن
ربما تنتهي بحساب النقاط على على المدى
البعيد او المتوسط طيب
كيف ترى الموقف الدولي هناك المزيد من
الدعوات والمناشدات لكلا الطرفين بوقف
القتال ومع ذلك لم نرى ضغطا حقيقيا بعد
كيف كيف يمكن تفسير ربما تكون هنالك اطراف
دوليه تريد لطرف من اطراف الصناعه يحسم
هذه الامر لان هذه الثنائيه القائمه الان
هي تعقد الاوضاع فربما تكون هنالك دعوات
انسانيه ودعوات سياسيه ولكن في الحقيقه
تكون هنالك اعين تنظر بعين خفيه
الات الصراع بانه لا بد ان يحسم لمصلحه
الطرف من اطراف الصراع ولكن ايضا بمواز
ذلك يتم الحديث عن مزيد من التدخل الخارجي
رغم نفي الطرفين لذلك اليوم في المقابلات
في المقابلتين مع الجزيره هناك حديث
متزايد عن تدخل خارجي وتدخل اسرائيلي كذلك
فيما فيما يحدث ايضا ما تداعيات كل ذلك
التدخل التدخل للايقاف امر والتدخل بان
هنالك اطراف اقليميه تريد ان تستثمر في
هذه المساحه هنالك اجند عابر للحدود ستاتي
الى السودان هذا امر اخر التدخل التدخل
الدعوات الانسانيه ودعوه الايقاف
والتهديدات لا اعتقد انها الان مثمره
الواقع الميداني هو الحاكم الان اما
التدخلات الاقليميه اذا تمددت اكثر واذا
استمرت اعتقد انها ستغيط من طبيعه الصراع
وقد تجعل من السودان مسرح اخر من مسارح
الصراع الانتيجتها دول الربيعه العربي
منها خاصه التجربه الليبيه قد يكون
السودان اقرب للتجربه الليبيه اذا تكاثبت
هذه التدخلات الاقليميه
كيف الامريكي لا سيما في ضوء التطور اليوم
بارسال بعثه عسكريه قريبه من السودان
تمهيدا ربما لاجلاء
الامريكيين وموظفي السفاره الامريكيه في
السودان ان حدث هذا الامر ما دلالاته وما
الذي يمكن ان ينتج القراءه الامريكيه بان
الحرب ستستمر وستتحول الى حرب اكثر شراسه
فبالتالي هي كانت في البدايه ترتجي ان
تحدث تهدئه وان يحدث التزام ولكن طالما ان
الاستجابه لم تكن تتم لذلك ليس امامهم
الخيار سوى ان يقوموا على الاقل في الحد
الادنى ان يقوم باخلاء البعثات
والوجود الامريكي في السودان وربما تنحو
دول اخرى
اوروبيه او اسيويه الى ذات النحل
طيب ايضا ماذا عن الاليه الثلاثيه كيف
تقيم تحركها حتى الان لسيما الاتحاد
الافريقي والايجاد يعني يتم الحديث عن
مبادرات للحلول ولكن لا يبدو وكانه هناك
تحرك على الارض عاجزه هذه القوه هي القوه
هذه تسببت في اشتعال هذا الخلاف بالاتفاق
الايطالي لاتفاق الايطالي كان اللعنه على
السودان ادى الى انقسام القوه السياسيه
وادى الى انقسام
قوى الحريه والتغيير والان يؤدي الى
انقسام المكون العسكري الى جيش ودعم سريع
ويؤدي الى احترام اعتقد ان المحطل الاساسي
ان القوه الاقليميه وبعض الاصناف الدوليه
لم تكن تعي طبيعه التعقيدات السياسيه لم
تكن تعي طبيعه التعقيدات العسكريه
فبالتالي اجرض تدخلات لم تكن حصيفه ولا
حكيمه فانتجت هذا الواقع المازون اشكرك
ضياء الدين بلال الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل
السياسي السوداني ضيفنا هنا في الاستوديو
شكرا لك